Bloomberg is one of the largest
technology companies in the world
pulling in over nine billion dollars in
2017 with over 20,000 employees we have
probably heard of Michael Bloomberg our
maybe read news on their website but
what exactly is Bloomberg even dude and
how did it get so big make sure you
stick around till the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to haria Celebes so all sort of
Michael Bloomberg graduated from John
Hopkins University with an electrical
engineering degree he would then get an
MBA at Harvard Business School and land
a job at an investment firm in New York
City called Salomon Brothers his first
task was very tedious with him having to
count out and organize millions of
stocks and bonds but thanks to his
quick-thinking and remarkable work ethic
he had quickly rise up and become a
partner by 1972 at the age of 30
this next task was to run the firm's
information technology system which is
again very very tedious and boring this
was he has the most glamorous portion of
the business as it was far from the
actual deals an action generating
revenue but Michael did deal with it
unfortunately though in 1981 Salomon
Brothers sold and Michael was sent off
it wasn't all bad though he had a ten
million dollar a severance package which
he used to set up a new information
technology company named innovative
market solutions this was very much
inspired by his work at Salomon Brothers
and he wanted to make brokerage work
much easier and less tedious and this
desire to make the process more
efficient is what would lead to his
first invention until now finding the
value of one security versus another was
very tedious and there really was no
progress since the 1960s it was just a
bunch of guys using number-two pencils
working all day he imagined building a
system that took information from
several different vestment types like
stocks bonds and currencies and
revealing the position of a firm at any
given point this opened up hidden
investment opportunities as revealed
previously inaccessible data to achieve
this he hired for Salomon Brothers and
former employees one of these four
people was Tom Segundo who will start
writing analytics programs and get to
work on what would soon become the
Bloomberg terminal
first target customer was merrill
lynch's capital market division michael
pitched an idea alone to head of the
division ed Moriarty and when Michael
finished presenting Moriarty asked to
head up the software division how long
it would take them to create it
themselves the head of the software
development team aleksandr told him that
if they didn't get any new work for the
next six months then they can start
right after michael immediately promised
that he would be able to get it done in
six months before they would even be
able to start and that they didn't have
to buy it if they didn't like it and
with that they really started to bring
the Bloomberg terminal to life they had
a significant advantage as I knew
exactly what investment firms were
looking for as they had all worked at
one before and this led them to create
the Bloomberg terminal which is still
heavily used even today it is regarded
as a professional investment system for
the financial marketplace so clearly the
Bloomberg terminal was of great use but
the only thing is that it is only
targeted at institutional investment
firms it is simply too expensive for
most individual investors and is
unfeasible for them today a subscription
to Bloomberg services costs twenty four
thousand dollars per user but if you
like two or more it's only twenty
thousand per user that's still a lot of
money but it is a sizable discount and
this is probably why you never knew a
Bloomberg did as they targeted niche
demographic that most of us don't have
any connection to the first system was
not elegant or complex but it was
resourceful and got the job done the
system provided price quotes and a lot
of messaging through a secure
proprietary network and for the end user
it was a windows-based application which
made it really convenient to use it with
Excel Excel is one of the most crucial
programs for the financial industry so
this was very important and as
technology has evolved they have also
started offering an online application
that can be accessed through mobile
devices portfolio managers and brokers
have the ability to use Bloomberg
anywhere services to access real time
market information any word in the world
this makes it very convenient and is a
huge advantage of Bloomberg subscription
but it wasn't an easy road though there
was a lot of competition from big
corporations as well Thomson Reuters I
can was her biggest competition which
still holds 25%
I could share even today Bloomberg still
has a slight edge holding 30% of market
share but clearly I can is not a joke
they also offer better value charging
four thousand dollars less per year at
twenty thousand dollars per year and
it's not just them there are also
several other companies we have sizable
chunks of market share and are also
cheaper as well
companies like fact set capital IQ and
simply just name a few Bloomberg is able
to deal with all this competition
because they are always one step ahead
by being the first in the market this
has made them the gold standard for
financial market news data and trading
tools today there are almost synonymous
with Wall Street and this lead helps
them out more than you would think even
though other services might offer
something cheaper and still provide the
same value it just convenient to stay
with Bloomberg trading firms don't need
to retrain staff and they don't have to
have a down time while software is being
updated on computers they have been
there for so long and it is just easier
to use the same soft great year after
year and for big firms like Goldman
Sachs an extra four thousand dollars
really is not worth going through all of
that hassle now there is some
disadvantages with using Bloomberg the
biggest of which is that they are slow
to adapt to new technology it took them
a pretty long time to adapt the 64-bit
systems but for the financial industry
this really doesn't matter because
they're not gonna be trying to remodel a
car or something they simply need data
and they don't need the most up-to-date
technology in order to do that plus it's
not like Bloomberg never adapts it just
takes them a little bit longer overall
Bloomberg is able to fend off a lot of
competition as they were the first in
the market firms are already Euston and
they don't see a need to change unless
someone else offers something
significantly different the slightly
cheaper price is really no big deal so
clearly Bloomberg terminals played took
off and even to this day Bloomberg
terminals make up most of their revenue
but since then they have also gone on
other ventures are not technology driven
for example they opened their own news
outlet 1991 called Bloomberg Business
News and their open offices in New York
London Toronto washing
gentoku and many more Bloomberg News has
always had a very editor driven culture
and they have a very specific way of
drying their articles in fact they have
their own book on how to write Bloomberg
articles called the Bloomberg way a
guide for reporters and editors they
even launched her own TV channel in 1994
called Bloomberg information TV they had
a variety of business-related shows and
news about the state of the economy and
financial industry as a whole they also
had their own magazine called Bloomberg
Businessweek this is a weekly American
business magazine but they didn't create
this one though this magazine actually
first published in September of 1929 and
it wasn't till July of 2009 almost
eighty years later they are acquired
this magazine the magazine had fell on
hard times after the 2008 economic
recession and Bloomberg would buy it for
two to five million dollars as it is
cleared since the terminal they have
also got several other ventures as well
today
Bloomberg is a major global provider of
financial news and information they
offer real-time and historic price era
financial data trading news and analyst
coverage as well as general news and
sports they have several services that
span across radio television and
magazines they offer professional
analysis tools for financial
professionals but even to this day
Bloomberg's key revenue earner remains
the Bloomberg terminal which is an
integrated platform the streams together
of price data financials trading data
and news he was also New York's he's
108th mayor serving from 2002 to 2013
there was also been a lot of rumors that
he's going to be running for president
but he's confirmed that he wanted do
less talking and more actual work he
says that Hugh Rowland sleeves up and
get to work and that he had no intention
for running for president but despite
that Michael Bloomberg and his company
are really quite inspirational Bloomberg
is a company that most of us have heard
about but really didn't know what they
did we have seen their magazines and
news articles but with actually their
background contribution to Wall Street
for terminals that really made them a
corporate giant they have
truly revolutionize the financial
industry eliminating the need for
tedious busy work and they have a lot
for much more effective investing across
Wall Street given this contribution it's
no wonder why they're so successful but
that's all I have for you guys on
Bloomberg make sure comment down below
what company you would like to really
cover next also if you guys like this
video then mention Thapa like and
consider subscribing if you like to see
more videos just like this one
when til then I'm Hardy I'll see you
guys on next one